feel like we can all breathe a sigh of
relief because according to reviews The
Dead Space remake is Good Game Informer
gave it a 9 out of 10 and said rather
than reinvent the wheel motive made Dead
Space look nicer play better and
preserved the core experience its new
flourishes add to that enjoyment instead
of subtracting which is exactly what I
want to hear Gamespot also gave it a 9
out of 10 saying the Dead Space remake
may not feel entirely necessary which
I'm inclined to agree with but it
improves upon the original with some
smart new additions to almost every
aspect of its design if the reason that
some of these Outlets aren't giving this
game a 10 is because it's not different
enough
IGN another 9 out of 10 said Dead Space
is a superb remake and undoubtedly the
definitive way to experience one of the
best survival horror shooters that
Capcom never made actually in this
entire thread which is aggregated by
Turbo straighter 27 on Reddit there are
only two reviews that were eight out of
ten couple of 8.5s but mostly nine or
higher you love to see it